hey everybody it's Charlie's surprise
surprise you guys may have heard the
news that apparently the TV show is
going to be doing Godspeed they're
currently filming season 5 episode 18
there were early reports that the title
of that episode was going to be wait for
it
Godspeed but a number of news outlets
were reporting the news without posting
any kind of evidence or anything like
that's why I was waiting to actually see
if we got any pictures or any kind of
video from behind the scenes and turns
out we just did so we'll break it down
the preview that we got also tells us a
little bit about the story they're using
him for in the context for where he
appears and what's going on when he
actually shows up and because they've
already done the big speed for storm on
the flash TV show I do have a theory
about how they can use crisis on
Infinite Earths as a way to explain how
August Hart gets his Speed Force
abilities and then eventually becomes
god speed so of course we'll do a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite God speed moment
from the comics on the video there have
been so many of you asking if they would
ever do god speed on the TV show and the
producers have always deflected and say
you know we're not gonna be doing big
speedster characters besides what's
going on with perverts flash this season
so the funny thing is is they're not
totally lying because of the way they're
using god speed when he appears on the
TV show and i think that they're setting
something up for a larger arc during
season 6 which I'll explain but lo and
behold thanks to a film student that was
camping the set in Vancouver we actually
have visual evidence we have touchdown
God speed has hit the flash TV show so
take a look at the costume we can freak
out about that because it does look like
a relatively accurate adaptation of God
speeds comic book suit but based on what
else is going on in the pictures we have
a really good idea of what his story is
when he appears during episode 18 so
just a reminder that that's what they're
filming here the next episode is gonna
be 15 that's the king shark versus Grodd
episode so god speed is still several
weeks away because there is no new flash
next week it's the week after that so
still two more weeks before we get a new
episode but this is what the suit looks
like with no special effects no color
correction no special lighting so you
have to assume that it's gonna pop a lot
more on-screen when he actually appears
in the real finished episode just like
Zoomers avatar when they're not
lit up and I'm assuming because of the
white costume with the yellow highlights
that he will be crackling with yellow
speedforce lightning like he does in the
comics yellow just pops a little bit
more on that white background that's why
the actual highlights like the little
lines on his suit our yellow themselves
just because they stand out so much even
if you're not a big comic book reader
you already know God speed is one of the
more badass speedsters in the DC
Universe but he's not the fastest the
reason why he's so dangerous is one
because he's mastered his abilities much
more than the other speedsters have but
the real reason why he's able to beat
the Barry Allen flash so handily is
because of his signature move he can
move so fast that he can create a
genuine duplicate of himself without
having to create a time remnant so he
explained her about his abilities the
reason why his name is God's speed is
because as the saying goes only God can
be in all places at once
in Detective auguste heart once against
the Speed Force learns to create
multiples of himself his ability is
sabot are proof though it's a master
molecule situation so when he splits
himself in two he does become weaker but
he's basically taking his own biology
and creating another version of himself
he's not jumping into the time stream to
pluck another version of himself from a
different point in time to team up with
himself so that's why the black flash or
time rays aren't chasing him down at
every turn when he creates duplicates of
himself his greatest weakness is that
when he creates the duplicate he's
severely weakened in both of those two
forms so if you have other multiple
speedsters teaming up that's usually how
you take him down I know a lot of you
are wondering though what happens if you
kill God speeds duplicate or if you kill
God speed would his duplicate become the
main version of God's speed and there's
actually no context for that yet they
haven't tested it what happened during
rebirth is that Wallace West jumped in
to team up with Barry on against the
duplicate God speeds and they were
forced to reform so that's the way they
defeated him based on the other stuff
that's going on in the background of
these pictures it seems like he's either
pursuing Nora in the future like this
2049 storyline or he's doing something
with her maybe other people in the
future find out what she's doing with
her first flash and those forces move to
stop her and god speed is just an agent
of that the reason why you can tell that
it's the future is because look at that
banner in the background it says central
city citizen that's irises newspaper so
even though
is not a date on it it just lets you
know that it's after irises newspaper
turns into a full-blown news agency
there's also the news feature depicting
a flash comic book moment with a villain
that we haven't seen on the show yet in
the way that the TV show explains comic
books is that all the flash comic books
that they were selling inside the flash
museum were based on the life of our
version of Barry Allen that we're
watching on the TV show right now so in
this universe on earth one in the future
DC Comics is created they start making
comic books based on the earth one
heroes so it's very cool very meta
Easter Egg but this actual comic book
panel is from flash vol 2 number 84
during the Mark Waid era of the flash so
the person that's in that red flash
costume is actually the ginger wally
west not barry allen fighting a villain
called razor his big thing is that he
wears this special teflon suit that can
get it cut through anything that's why
he's called razor because he cuts stuff
in the story depicted by this comic book
panel he was hired by an evil developer
to extort money from competing
businesses he'll destroy them if they
don't pay up then as you would expect
the wally west flash tries to take him
down the other really cool Easter Egg
too is the Tina McGee is also a
character during this comic book issue
obviously Tina McGee big character on
the flash TV show we haven't seen her in
a while but this is just confirmation
that the flash TV show will probably do
that raiser character in some future
episode next season they call their
shots a lot like when abracadabra names
all those villains off and he names the
thinker then later in the season
Savitt are also for a second time named
drops the thinker then he became the
villain during season four here it is in
the future you and I have been enemies
for years
but none of them hurt you likes Avatar
this is where we came up with the
cerebral inhibitor to use against the
bow so rule of thumb anytime you see a
comic book panel on the flash TV show
like inside the flash museum and he's
fighting a character that we haven't
seen yet it means that they're gonna do
that character in a future episode at
some point I know there are a billion
more questions about godspeed but if you
look at the stuntman that's in the suit
he looks a little bit bigger it looks
like he's gonna be a little bit older in
this future timeline when he encounters
Nora so I assumed that when he shows up
is just him in the costume speaking with
a modulated voice so that they can then
later cast an actual actor for August
heart maybe they know who that's going
to be maybe they don't know maybe
they're just gonna wait till next season
but I'm guessing that he probably only
appears briefly in these future scenes
for now we don't see him in present day
quite yet so the during season six we
meet a younger version of August Hart
who comes to work at the Central City
Police Department as a detective
eventually gets paired up with Barry
Allen and we can slowly see his origin
story play out over the course of season
six or season seven whatever their plan
is for developing god speed as a
character on this show because I think
the reason why they would do God's be
this way like show you full-blown god
speed before they show you August heart
is is because they recognize that he's
likely most popular flash character
besides Barry Allen in the world right
now so pretty much anybody even if you
don't read comics you probably know who
God speed is and as a fan they don't
want to make you go through the
excruciating process of showing you
August heart and then making you wait an
entire year to see whether or not he's
gonna turn into god speed they're
calling their shot Babe Ruth style we
are definitely doing Godspeed then the
drama of why he becomes god speed will
be the story of a future season in some
form whatever their plans are for August
heart on the TV show so for now just
consider the story of August heart in
the story of Godspeed two different
things and we'll just see the God speed
stuff accelerated man style
remember-when accelerated man showed up
during season three we didn't get a
really big story he just did a bunch of
cool stuff and then we didn't see him
again till next season
that might be what happens with god
speed during season five just like
here's a really badass thing that we're
gonna turn into a bigger story in a
future season remember they said that
they were going to do a speedster as the
main villain
during season five in true to form
reverse-flash is not the main villain
even though there's a lot of subtext
there and obviously God speed doesn't
seem like he's a huge huge character
during season five so if they do him
during season six it's also another way
to do a speedster as a main villain
without doing him as a main thorn
because God speed is more like the Red
Hood of the flash family more of an
antihero than a straight-up villain
because it's sort of a fall from grace
because August heart becomes one of
Barry Allen's best friends before he
gets Speed Force powers and turns into
god speed so we'll talk more about his
backstory if we learn a little bit more
about what the TV show is gonna do
within this season let me know in the
comments if they're doing god speed in
the future timeline now what do you want
them to do with August heart during
season six
because fingers crossed what they could
do is they could use crisis on Infinite
Earths as a way to explain how August
heart gets Speed Force powers during
season six in present day if they bring
him on the show post all your reactions
in the comments below will freak out
about this for a while there'll be a
bunch of trailers posting in the next
couple of weeks so just look out for
that I'll do videos for everything new
Marvel phase four posting tonight as
well click here to rewatch that flash
king shark vs. Grodd trailer video and
click here for my brand new spider-man
far from home trailer with a new
avengers endgame timeline of major
events thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]